uh thunderhorse one warzone rated
71 gladiators
average rating
1753 time and position handicapped
30 minutes coming up
here we go
first game of the thunder horse
matt e joy let's jump right into it
you know the drill
fiend kettle land
that's right i didn't forget to enter
the tournament
i saw that
right out of the corner of my eye
the advanced thunderhorse
oh i just dropped my bishop why'd you do
that i should i have their bishop
i had their bishop right there
ah
man
i had their bishop
i could have just taken their bishop
i would get that guy i'm going to track
that bishop down you know you want to
play here
oh
okay let's do this
oh wait a second and i lost my right to
throw the blue chicken gambit out there
can i get the rook
yes i got the queenie
i got the rook oh it's falling down now
falling downtown
whoa
i'm ready to be trapped here
i gotta do this i think
my queen is out of squares get out of
there night
get out of there bishop actually it's
not okay here here here here 24 24.
oh man
okay the night is pinned the night is
pinned the knight is still pinned the
knight is no longer pinned
grab that pawnee
wow
wow grab a knight
now what
resign
where's the mates
give a check and then a mate
move bishop you know you want to move
or night
you know you want to move i should just
captured and run the pond stop it are
they in zig swaying
uh oh
finally this took forever
back to tournament
holy smokes
28 big ones i'm up there with two
wow
oh man
oh
man
wow what do you do with two
you can't win if you only have two
points take the pawn he's free
power
yes
suggestion wins again
power of suggestion
yo
what is that light square bishop up to
let's shut him down
oh
get out there night
okay i'm gonna take that in between her
watch out they're very deadly
watch out for those
in-betweeners double rooks double
trouble
kill a knight
ah
this is a bit scary
i get rid of that night can we get rid
of that night
forks oh
i got a block like this i didn't want to
walk into a discover check
get my king up get my bishop to d6 and
then look for me
where's the mate
get out of there
okay let's bump the king upon pushy
pawn pushy pawn pushy rook fork
mate coming up incoming maitland
they're in a pickle the rook has to go
back the bishop better not go too far
away
they're running out of moves
past pawn
coming up past pawn get the past pawns
pass pawns anything
anything
burn their time no time back to
tournament
40 39 30 26 what happened
what's happening here
i have the blue chicken gambit i could
launch that thing in a blink
any second it can happen
okay g4 don't you dare quit
don't you dare quit
there's a lot of time left you can do it
okay
i don't want to give that pawn up let's
get this pawn right here i want to force
that so i can get this open file
open file open sesame
okay let's do this queen you know you
want to be on h4 and the h-pawn is going
to capture soon very soon very scoot
very schoon
open this up here open open open why did
i do that
why did i do that
why do you do such things
oh boy this is a disaster
in
fear the in-betweener
a queen has to take
knight right here
what
this is going to lead to me no what am i
doing i have checkmate why didn't i just
play queen h7
ah this better lead to mate is it
leading to me it's not leading to mate i
missed a main one
oh
no
no say isn't so
no no no no no no no no no no no
oh i had a main one why would i ever do
something like that
never do that again ever
get the queen now
get that queen and you better at least
win this game
wow
this game could have been i only have i
don't know how much time
i don't have any time
oh i got the rook at least
ah i gotta time burners four
three two
what's the clock situation
clock situation
time time time time time time time time
oh man
56 where where are my points
what's happening here
what what's going on here
i only have
oh man
okay they're down um they're less than a
minute
i got a lot of homework to do
everybody in 30th place
wow
wow
how did how does this happen
i'm doubling those points aren't i
oh
man
this is brutal look at this
wow
86 players i'm holding down 30th really
well nobody's
nobody's gonna get past me
12 points you can't overcome that
oh man
this guy is just a time ticker
the shepherd
shepherd
let's go here
oh
game four man i need a lot of help i
need a lot of help and i don't think
it's to be coming
how do you how do i only have 12 points
i'm only going up four
there's something wrong there's got to
be a glitch
i'm only getting four points
i i'm not even other i think everybody
else is getting 10 and 20.
i'm getting 4-2
i think this happened the last time
what's going on is somebody hitting me
with like um
it was i uh was this did i have this
coming
ever since i started using the blue
chicken gambit
oh man
i will never use that again i'm sorry
this is my punishment
oh man
this is my punishment here
okay the bishop's in a pin black should
be fearing the worst you see the points
are doubled in this game
right
the points are doubled
come on my queen wants to get to g2 you
know you want to take the pun take him
yes come on give me ten i got 10 points
i'm in double digits
oh
26 i'm holding strong is there a way to
come back
that's what everybody wants to know
and i don't have answers to these
questions hang on to a rook though you
don't want to drop that
come on h-pawn save the day
save the day h pun
okay let's play here my light square
bishop wants to do something else come
over here it's nice and cozy
looking for the cozy positions
oh
i'm trying to
win here i'm not able to win
development
tuck my king in he's going to be nice
and cozy i'm going to drop my rook but
hopefully i could um
do something with the light square
bishop
okay let's weasel around no no no no
don't you dare try to trade queens
no i will have none of that
i gotta get rid of that night that night
needs to go
you need to go night
and it's not so easy
no no no no what is that movie been
doing queen right here is gonna be good
okay
this is scary come on light squares
light squares light squares you know you
want to move knight you know you want to
move
come on
no i don't want to trade this much and
then it's happening though
it's happening whether i like it or not
it's happening
just working out it's not working out
i'm dead
this is me this is me
no i want to cry
mate you can't go backwards and win
minus two oh
minus two
you're going backwards and i want to cry
oh i need a kleenex kleenex variation
that's what i'm getting hit with right
now grab that pawn how many times are
you going to have that pawn on a g7
knight g3
g5 don't you dare give up hope
don't you dare
self pep talk engaged it's engaged the
self pep talk
don't you dare quit
you don't have any quit in you
or do you i do actually i do have quit
whether you realize it or not
these thunder horses i just can't stop
laughing
okay come on queen
because the king wants to castle queen
side there you go nice and easy you can
do it dodge discover tricks over here
it's safe and sound even though you're
losing your f pawn no you're not
pawn push more discovered tricks
for karowski
beware
watch out for the forks this rook was
hanging for seven turns and it could be
hit again just taken forks everywhere
there you go
my queen is hit pieces are falling
everywhere my queen can be taken are
they gonna take it take the queen it's a
freebie
what's going on here
queen takes queen there's seven pieces
that can be taken okay defend like a
champ
you can do this
get a queen they'll never suspect it oh
they're gonna grab this guy got the
queen but it's coming back around the
bishop pair
everybody loves the bishop pair
get out of tricks
no i don't want to trade i have very
i have very little fuel left you're
trying to get rid of my fuel
right here forks pins skewers you name
it time burners time burners time
burners
ron king
run for the hills
back to tournament i'll take it i only
have 36
i'm struggling to get top ten
oh
okay
here we go here we go
what's going on here i don't understand
why um
are there glitches still going on
there there's got to be what i don't
understand how the how it's so low
i gotta put in a message listen
i played this tournament the other day
and my score was so low
it should never be like that should
never be like that what did i do to
deserve such a low score how should i
phrase that one
they'll get back to me and say you gotta
play better
that's your problem you're not playing
better
okay exploit the pin that's what it's
all about hit this the pawn is pinned
hit a knight grab a queen
pressure points where the pressure
points let's do this
open it up
let's go
don't be scared grab this pun
open this up too it's probably good
night here is probably good i think oh
no just getting they're getting that
i'm on that i'm on that i'm on that i'm
on the queen
oh
uh oh
i want to hang out with that bishop
there let's grab here
rooks pigs pigs pigs
a lot of pigs here
oh queen
everybody loves a free queen looking for
mates
where are the mates
grab a knight
this is mate got enough on it
come on
what do we have here back to tournament
50 oh
could i get top 10 there's 15 minutes
left
you can do it
come on this guy's up there he's got 84.
has he seen this variation before though
that's the big question he's got 84 but
has he seen the thunderhorse
variation
this is a good move a4b4c5
ah my knight landing on f5 very soon
i'm on the bishop be scared be very very
scared take that pawn give me something
to play for
let me take this open it up open it up
open it up even at the cost of a pun
the knight's gonna take
and i gotta get queen side castle
here we go
another file opening up let's get this
in double drop double trouble
double trouble incoming double trouble
incoming what do you do what do you do
what do you do
let's go for the queen
this pond is getting killed
i think this is working out somehow pawn
takes i take this knight and then i take
this knight and it leads to mate by
force
is this working
hey let's just make sure of it
because he's going down next i think
okay
there's no mates here is there
rook takes knight
uh oh
uh oh he's a good defender this bishop
master defender and attacker
dual purpose guy
chekarooski's
okay
he's gonna hit that knight again
let's grab this rook first and go here
watch out for the mates
okay they're down on time back to
tournament
66
holy smokes
oh these are the most difficult ones i
need my bishop puns take a knight but
don't take my bishop ponds whatever you
do
uh i gotta trade queens now i think okay
they're not going for that they should
have gone for that
let's try this
let's go after that king
check
and then here
looking for a quick kill
where are the quick kills
oh i got this
and then
where where's the what's the follow-up
oh oh i got the rook oh
okay this is this is pretty good
this is winning isn't it
oh oh oh i'm getting trapped
or close to it actually i could give a
check here
give a check here and then land my
knight on b4 i think is good
they're not moving
they have less than 30.
check right here no matter what maybe
not okay mate threats
gotta trade queens i guess
knight right here forks
forks family fork
i'm on the queen and then the rook at
the end of it i should have thrown in a
check or something oh this is check and
then grab this night
grab this night
and then give a check
no time they're down they're down back
to tournament 84 225
225.
this guy is 169. oh wait a second this
is the first time
hang on there's no need for thunderhorse
i can play an actual game now
i can actually play a game can you
believe that looking for forks
forks
get the center get the center get the
center get the center pawn push kick
that knight away but not so fast there's
no need to do it fast
okay this recaptured get out of there
play here and then pawn push next
overtaking the center the knight has to
run away scared
get out of there bishop
get out of here night
don't go there night
let's get developed finally you've made
enough pond moves your king
wants to be where right up here king g3
you're gonna love that square
king g3 it's nice and cozy oh or is it
okay let's let's play here before it's
too late
oh my knight is there to defend or it's
not
whoa did i miss that whoa did i miss
that and that and this and my rook oh is
everything falling or what
there's no defense is there oh i'm
getting killed i'm getting killed i'm
getting killed pieces are falling
everywhere
oh man
i don't have anything this is going to
be a brutal mate
oh what happened here i don't have any
time
is this working out i'm getting mated
oh i got to do this
and then
i gotta do that
this is so bad you can't get out of this
can you no
this guy is killing me
oh where did all my pieces go i want
some pieces back
oh i got the queen i got the queen i got
the queen hang on hang on
hang on don't don't fear don't fear no
fear no fear
no fear
where's the fear
is there any fear
over here over here over here over here
pre moves where are the pre moves where
the pre moves
oh how much time how much time i don't
have any time
oh i'm down on time i can't believe my
sword came back
i was in thunderhorse more
moored
oh man that was a disaster
how did i oh i was pinned why'd i let
that rook get to what square was it d3
that was a disaster
just as i was saying i wanted some
pieces back
i got a piece back the queen
my opponent took their queen and said
here take it
you could take that and i'm still going
to beat you over the head
oh what can you do
oh what can you do how much time is left
this guy is not moving eight minutes and
change
and i am way out of tenth place or uh
better
82.
wow i've never seen anything like this
before
this is crazy even if i won all my games
i only have 11 in
and i'm
i'm still in two-digit land oh man
two-digit land i need 18 resigners in a
row can i get 18 resigners
oh man
give me the resigners let's go yes there
we go give me those points
don't you dare give up seven minutes is
plenty
party rock
let's go party rock
hang on
okay i'm coming at my opponent hard
minus the minor pieces i'm still coming
at him
oh man i wish i knew that i was actually
playing that one minute game
with the full with the full deck there
i was actually playing with the full
deck
i wouldn't have played b3
ah
i still i had a good position though oh
i can't shake that game
i got crunched
that queen h4 move i was trying to take
it did you see me
my knight was here i'm like oh it was a
free queen i was like that you can't do
that if you're in a pin silly
and i was pinned
okay knight an f6 needs to go
somewhere else
okay
let's go here even though it's gonna get
kicked around
let's go upon do something bishop h here
here oh i'm having flashbacks of that
game two seconds ago oh
pieces are sneaking in right here g4
bad stuff happens oh kill the knight why
not kill a knight if it's free
that was a free night
a bishop here or night here
something here and then grab here pawn
push here
uh
knight here i take this pawn i think and
then follow up with rook here
oh man
nine less than ten
holy smokes i i'm afraid to even look at
the top scores
oh
so far away
come on they have to check the server on
this one too
oh this is disaster this is disaster
land
how much time there's like six minutes
okay finally i'm getting 20 points for a
win
20 points for a win
oh
come on a quick resigner it's my only
hope
18 quick resigners is all i
need 18
oh they're gonna hit my queen i could
feel it yep there i knew that was coming
the bishop's ready to be cooked
let's go let's go knight
give me that bishop can i get that
bishop actually i could do this and win
it there's going to be bishop takes here
or something i could actually take it
though
because my queen could defend here
or can it oh i have to run for the hills
my rook is dead over here queen takes
pawn oh it was missed
okay get out of there
sneaky bishop
watch out for the sneaky bishop
okay let's take it i shouldn't have
taken it
uh i don't want to trade too much but it
looks like i'm going to have to or am i
sneaky oh
pigs pigs pigs he's a hungry pig
stay hungry pig
i got to do this otherwise the rooks are
going to give me a giant headache i got
one pig that's active that's all i need
actually he's ready to be trapped the
king was ready to run over there
let's give a check
oh i need time burners like you have no
idea my rook is the only one that could
do that he's my last time burner
time burner
you can do it you can do it
oh
can you give a check come over here
oh oh oh oh what's happening here defend
like a champion
just defend come over here checks on the
king
don't give check to my king whatever you
do
don't you dare time burner
over here
pin upon
time burners time burners time burners
where are you
time burners where are you where are you
i gotta give a check like this and over
here i'm getting mated
or am i
time burners
time burners what do i got i'm up i'm up
i'm up they're down on time
oh just enough gas left
why play checkers uh
why play without those bishop puns
oh
hang on
hang on i'm gonna just not recapture and
then support my bishop right here he
wants to be supported
and
okay well let's depend support this guy
castle
and then
pin this knight
and uh get my other knight doing
something
pins pins ah sneakiness sneakiness
sneakiness that does not come with check
that's why i pull through my king in the
corner
give a check here pig
pig pig pig pig
uh oh
uh oh bad news bad news
bad news
bad news
for who
for me
night moves i give checkmate they
resigned back to tournament 152.
actually something in my voice just said
i actually had hope but i really don't
have hope
i got excited for a half a second right
there i was like oh
back to tournament i'm gonna gain 18
1800 points for that
i'm fixated on that 18.18 number by the
way if you haven't noticed i don't know
why
it's either 18 it's 1800
okay i'm gonna take this guy
oh okay i get that piece back
let's just post up here
and then here you know you want to just
fall for me in one
is there hope
there's no hope oh i get a rook at least
out of it
give a check check over here check
everywhere
check here
check here
grab this
check here inbetweeners
a lot of inbetweeners happening
okay i've had my fun
let's cash in
cash in after the smoke is cleared black
is up material but how much time is left
give a check here it's probably good and
this is mate
sort of
not much more there's no sort of
oh there's no sort of what are you
talking about right here four karuski's
move rook
let's get this guy
and then
where's the mate where's the mate you
know you want a mate that's mate that's
mate that's made back to termite 172
343 323
wow
there goes the queen knight
how much time do i have
one minute warning
okay i gotta do something real clever
where's the real clever stuff
could it happen this bishop needs to be
on f7 somehow can i make that happen
can i make that happen f7 needs to be
targeted
my g pawn wants to play and i don't want
to drop a bishop
knight wants to be here and my queen
doesn't want to be dead
temple temple temple temple i'm on the
bishop
kick a knight around
get out of there knight this is not
happening get out of there bishop f7
i got to get a f7 i'm just going to do
it even if it's wrong push i need to get
at f7
move knight
you know you want to move
pawn push
clock burner
check
oh they're ready to give mate
i would have screamed oh
thanks for playing
24th don't you dare look at that i'm
gonna put my mouse over it
i got
second
where's my confetti if i'm getting
second
second out of 95.
okay let's close that out real quick
oh man
look at this
363
323.
look at me all the way down here at 16
games
27 games this guy had in
that is a ridiculous amount
25 25 23 20 21 23 19 23 16.
wow
not even close good games oh